how do you go about decrypting ciphered
traffic that uses these enigma machines
can you do by hand and what actually
happened at Bletchley Park what
historically was the order in which
things took place this has been very
much prompted by the appearance of the
film called the imitation game with
Benedict Cumberbatch as Alan Turing
afraid these men would only see me down
popular at school way two of the first
people through the doors of Bletchley
Park in September 39 were Alan Turing
and his colleague at Cambridge another
mathematician called Gordon welchman who
I think was a year ahead of Alan Turing
actually in taking the master tripod and
of course getting there first you will
find throughout the story Bletchley Park
was full of first-class mathematicians
even before war broke out the Allies had
had a big success in that a German spy
had actually defected before the war
started and handed over a military
Enigma machine and a starter Enigma code
book what better tutorial I think he
handed it over to the French Secret
Service the French contacted the English
who were by that stage had moved to
Bletchley Park
their chief crypt analyst was a guy
called Dylan hogs who'd had a lot of
success with this stuff going back to
this world war but I mean to cut a long
story short the the French and the
British initially did they just did not
want to do know what to do with this
stuff war hadn't yet broken out but
fortunately the French I think passed it
on and the conditions of great secrecy
to the Polish cipher Bureau and we and
Bletchley Park owed them a lot because
they had a team there led by a very very
good mathematician called marian
rejewski
he spotted straightaway that with all of
this system of rotors reflectors plug
boards it was basically just running
through the permutations so what better
way to really get to grips with all of
this and all of its possibilities than
to have somebody with an expert
in what's called the theory of
permutation groups and marian rejewski
was very good from that point of view
they were dealing with machines where
there were just three rotors six
combinations no choices of three out of
five at that stage and that made life a
lot simpler a plugboard did come along
and the poles originally found that they
could invent what you might call by hand
methods they used a method of perforated
sheets and amazingly by sliding these
over one another and perforating them
according to the ciphertext that you
received but as it became more and more
complicated it really did need some
machinery and full credit to the poles
they realize this and they built a
machine called the bomba and with the
bomba so long as it was only three
wheels so long as the weren't too many
cross settings on the plugboard on input
and output and so long as the initial
message setting was transmitted in a way
that got bound by the end of 1938 as the
Germans realized it was not very secure
essentially you chose a three letter
word and you sent it twice and even
though it appeared at the other end is
six cryptographically mapped symbols you
know you might type in ins the german
word so it's happening twice once once
and it would appear as ljq wxz
something like that nevertheless if you
knew that those first six letters had to
map into a repeated German three-letter
word boy did it cut down the number of
settings of the Enigma that could
possibly have produced that so with all
those simplifications and weaknesses the
poles are able to make a very good start
what really blew them out of the water
first of all was tragically being
invaded of course by Germany how can you
run a cipher Bureau and any sort of
operation when your country's being
invaded but even prior to that the idea
of choosing three out of five
before you arranged the three on the
spindle as we've seen that led to 60
combination
they need not six bombi but 61b how's
the question couldn't afford it pressure
in Poland was such that they probably
never get around to building them anyway
handing over of the whole situation as
to where the bullish Bambara got to God
Bletchley Park off to a flying start
I mean clearly they were up against
bigger plug boards not just three out of
five rotors but looking at the naval
stuff coming along as looking like three
out of eight the whole idea of machinery
was an excellent one but he had to be
made even more powerful and robust it
was driven by land cheering and of
course as we now know he was put on the
ideal persons to do it not only was he a
theoretical mathematical logician while
he was at Princeton he'd actually built
hardware he loved soldering relays
together making his own little replicas
of how his Turing machines might work as
people will tell you Alan Hodges in the
biography says he was hammer fisted he
was enthusiastic but not good is it
Sean Wiley is colleague in Hatay said
very enthusiastic but he was so clumsy
he used to insist on using high voltage
so luring ions because they were more
efficient and he'd give himself electric
shocks and if it wasn't an electric
shock making him scream he'd burned
himself and no enthusiasm but not the
person you would want to build your home
computer he said look we've got to do
this by building a bomb let's call it a
bo MBA partly with a nod in the
direction of the polls and saying thank
you he drew up a specification of what
needed to be done you see this in action
in the imitation game I'm designing a
machine
will allow us to break every message
every day incidentally but the good
thing of course in the movie is that it
doesn't have to produce any results it
just has to rotate a lot and look very
very impressive thanks to a superb
effort what is now the Bletchley Park
Museum they've actually rebuilt a bomb
and it works but let's just explain that
for every vertical column of three in
this decryption device the top one here
on the bomb corresponds to the rightmost
drum the fastest one the middle one
corresponds the middle one and the
bottom one of the three in any column
corresponds to the leftmost drum which
was rotating slowest of all essentially
what you've got is lots and lots of
enigmas in parallel as it were and you
can try out different menus as they will
call different programs basically saying
well you see that enigma replica at the
top left I'd like to make the top drum
be a type two drum the middle one be a
type five in the bottom one be a type
three because I think that was the drum
ordering and on those drums I'd like to
make the ring settings you know where
you put your little stud to do the
initial offset I'd like to make them
reading from the top V a and H can you
do that please oh and this is where
Turing's ideas came in he said look you
know we are going to have to get more
and more and more into the idea of
decrypting by trying to use known
plaintext you know if you're listening
in to a certain weather station that's
sending out in Enigma code you know that
phrases like storm and heavy rain and
stuff are going to occur sometimes you
wouldn't succeed you know you'd have to
give up and so no I think that our idea
was wrong we'll have to try something
else the fact that enigma never
enciphered anything to itself was a huge
help if you look at James Grimes video
you can see him using pieces of paper
tape as it were to show ciphertext and
showing some guest plain text underneath
it and you slide them along and you keep
on trying different
and if it's a given position a letter in
the ciphertext exactly corresponds to a
letter in the plaintext then that cannot
be right you can't have an A encrypting
as an A so you must keep sliding it
along this guest plaintext and you might
stand a chance at the places where there
are no correspondences there's no places
where a letter is encrypted to itself
and I think one of the stories told was
that they sent out an RAF plane to bomb
a crucially important light boy at the
mouth of a harbor yeah and then knew
which station we'll be reporting that
back to headquarters listened to the
ciphertext looking for I think it's the
German would something like alloy -
toner for light boy and if you see
something saying you know the light boy
has been destroyed wonderful you've got
known plaintext now allegedly the house
itself was nowhere near big enough to
accommodate all of the personnel that
were needed it wasn't just Crypt
analysts and mathematicians it was
service personnel intelligence people
Clark's admin all that stuff so as well
as occupying the entirety of the house
out in the grounds there were various
huts and different units with different
tasks or in different huts the
three-rotor
Army and Air Force enigma service was
based in her six it was run by Gordon
welchman and Turing's near contemporary
her Cambridge the bigger problem the
much harder problem was naval enigma as
we've already discovered naval enigma
didn't just choose three rotors out of
five H o three rotors out of eight
massively complicating things and then
doughnuts the head of the German Navy
being yet more suspicious and wanting
his codes to be super secure introduced
the idea of a fourth rotor and I think
that was particularly so for the u-boat
traffic now that was a much harder
problem so for a long time three rotor
enigma could almost go into production
four-rotor enigma was still at the
research stage
and for some desperate months I think in
late 41 early 42 there was a time when
naval ending was off the air completely
they just couldn't get into it they
couldn't decrypt anything I think they
were helped eventually by a pinch which
was to get a codebook off a submarine
that had been depth charge shattered by
depth bombs the stricken reader is
abandoned one of dozens that are meeting
the same thing and gradually as their
skills built up they were more and more
successful with naval enigma but I think
you could say even right to the end of
the war it was always harder than doing
the Army and the Air Force stuff so what
he came down to then Bletchley was hut 6
3 rotor enigma at 8 navel for rotor or
three rotor enigma all done in hut 8
under Alan Turing now when you now look
at the imitation game you will notice
that it's all centered around Hut eight
massive simplification they merge Hut
six personnel in with Hut aid personnel
they mentioned Hugh Alexander the double
British chess champion quite right he
was there without insuring in hut 8 they
mentioned this wonderful extension to
the back of the bomb called a diagonal
board which helps a lot it was a bright
idea and the implication is given in the
imitation game that this was invented by
Hugh Alexander no it wasn't it was
invented by Gordon welchman of hurt
sakes but this is Hollywood for you you
have to live with us yes there was a guy
called Jack good in cut eight you'll see
him in the movie as well he was a very
good statistician almost as good as Alan
Turing himself and was also good at
chess but not as good as you Alexander
and yes Joan Clarke it's not an
artificial oh we must have a woman in
this let's make one oh no she really
existed she also had a first class maths
degree from Cambridge she went to the
women's college noonim but Gordon
welchman I think had been one of her
tutors or one of her
hasn't thought highly over so again
spoiler alert
inside the imitation game Joan Clarke
did not get recruited as a result of
doing a crossword puzzle in five minutes
and 34 seconds she got recruited because
Gordon Welsh weren't around jury knew
all about her and just took great care
to get hold of her they started building
machines with the help of a very
talented hardware engineer called doc
keen or Harold keen to give his proper
name you had to work out the wheel
combinations and the wheel ordering
first of all you needed BOM time to try
them out and in the early days doc keen
did his best and made I think bonds that
could be used for either three rotor or
four row to work at six needed them all
the time for production work you know
they pretty well knew what the settings
were straightforward but they needed
bond time when you say production
working that is you're talking about
just day to day decoded day to day
decoding we know we're going to crack
this you know we're just set it just
send it through just double-check that
this is right you know so but you know
with the Army and Air Force stuff they
were never in any serious doubt that
from about late 41 onwards they could do
it what you didn't want was the hot
eight mob coming in and saying it's our
turn on that machine now it's not fair
we meant to share these things
the problem for Tait you see was that
their usage was a lot more speculative
it would lead to a lot more failures
until you got some idea of what the
wheel ordering was and then Alan Turing
came up with a really very very bright
idea we showed how good a statistician
he was what he said was look we could
maximize our what's a word payoff from
these bombs if only we knew without
getting on to the things which wheels
were in use at the right in the middle
those are the ones that are going to
rotate first you know you're feeding
your first bit of ciphertext it's the
right one that goes around 26 times and
then the next one starts move some other
time you've done 600 and whatever 26
squared is characters
you've seen a fair bit of ciphertext if
you take that ciphertext and think that
it came from German but with certain
wheel settings on the right in the
middle but we don't know them yet
what do you know from the frequency
statistics of letters in German as to
how that might give it the give itself
away a little bit
even in ciphertext depending on exactly
what the cross wirings were in the right
and the middle rotors in other words
could we say that a number one and a
number three rotor that we're trying
here matches this vague matching process
rather better than a number five and
number two those of you who know some
statistics will realize this is
conditional sequential Bayesian
probabilities and all that happened when
you convoluted as it were arbitrary
German texts with this ciphertext is
certain little indications would come
and they didn't do it on the bomb they
did it by another method of sheets and
their sheets were made in Banbury you
punched holes in sheets and put them
over in light box and slid one over the
other and you looked at these great long
strings of stuff coming out with certain
little groupings of letters there that
were giving the game away statistically
it turned out that it was deadly work
you had to concentrate and yet not fall
asleep and you had to remember what had
gone before you had to try and think
what might come up I don't understand
all the details but I'm not surprising
the slightest to find that the person
who was best at spotting this was Hugh
Alexander the chess champion and by
common consent in hut 8 he was the best
probably the next best second equal I
think was Jack good also a statistician
and a good chess player but I don't play
chess but Hugh Alexander was top board
or Bletchley Jack good was fourth board
right those two but I think she was
under thought the world of Joan Clark he
thought that possibly
Jack with the next-best after him and
decoding using this Alan Turing
technique which because it used sheets
made in Banbury was inevitably given the
latinized name of bambor isthmus but it
was helpful because if you did it
properly you could say we can reduce the
time on the bomb when we get on to it
because we know that this ciphertext
really is almost certainly come from
having a number five in the middle and
the number one on the right so all we've
got to do is to work out what the left
rotor is so just as a very rough color
for instance that is that might be
something like there we know e comes up
normally Evolet exactly hell and all
sorts of things but knowing they known
the cross wirings of those two that
you're assuming you could work out how
the pattern of heavy e's would come out
into certain other patterns that would
give the game away but only
ever-so-slightly would look almost
random but not quite and you had to be
trained how to spot the non-randomness
what helped a lot of course was when
they started building more bombs and
even for production work from her three
there's no way that the bombs that could
build a blast apart were enough they had
to start putting them out in other
derelict manor houses within about a 20
mile radius they ended up I think by the
beginning 42 with about three of the
manor houses full of bombs eventually
six by the end of the war I think the
overall estimates are that there were
about 40 or 50 bombs of various sorts in
the UK when you added how many of the
were it built in America because that
was the other factor the plans for all
these were handed over to the Americans
special relationship all that taken to
America and with America not being under
daily air raids and having no shortage
of raw materials they built I think in
the end something approaching a couple
of hundred bombs of various sorts and
the interesting story is that in late 42
early 43 I think it was Alan Turing made
a journey
America and went to see the naval
decryption operation and also the the
army one as well because there was
separate in America not under combined
roof as they were at Bletchley and I
think the naval Admirals were really
right at the start of the war you know
very worried saying we can build this
machinery but but you know we're up
against it we've got done it's against
us he's three out of eight not three out
of five now our mathematician people
tells us three out of eight turns out to
be 336 okay Allen so here's the deal
we've got to build 336 of these bombs
haven't we and now said though you don't
you use my bamboo business technique you
can to sort out which routers you almost
certainly have got off the bomb before
you ever get on it and then you can make
do and I think they thought this was
wonderful I think in the end they built
I don't know what the compromise was to
build somewhere between sixty and a
hundred rather than 336 but so high-lead
did they think of this technique the
Americans that was a very interesting
story
that conditional sequential Bayesian
probability bamboo isthmus technique has
been classified from then until 2010
that's how sensitive it was the reason
that made it even more sensitive was
that it wasn't just used in four-rotor
naval enigma where it was important but
he fed on into the other machine that
we're going to do a separate video about
at some stage the well-known Colossus
machine that technique was of great use
there as well one final indication of
how they got on top of the problem again
from Hugh Alexander with use of the
Bamber isms techniques the sheets and
extra bomb time that was the pod
everybody wanted bomb time they
eventually got enough and what Alexander
said I had no idea this took place he
said you do realize of course that they
weren't all physically in England we had
dedicated transatlantic underwater
cables between us and the
nc our place which was doing naval
enigma in the USA so they were very nice
we didn't have to ship any of their
machinery over to us which we wouldn't
have never been allowed to do but what
we did was we just sent our jobs over to
them the ones that we didn't have the
bomb time to do we could send them the
menu these settings on the bomb plan
border to enable you to set up the drums
to be of a certain type and in a certain
order and ring settings and all that so
the full spec for that menu which we
would call program nowadays could be
sent over the undersea cable and the
result usually came back within an hour
and that made a huge difference to the
amount of traffic they could get on top
of so it's sobering to reflect that just
over 70 years ago now it's rather than
undersea fiber-optic or anything like
that even on good old-fashioned undersea
copper cables you were still sending
programs into the cryptographic cloud as
it were at the other side of the
Atlantic suddenly Bob goes ballistic
stretches his arms out in front of a
display and say you will close this down
now ken Thompson and Dennis Ritchie and
they were given the Turing award